when Aegon the Conqueror invaded
Westeros he had seven kingdoms to
contend with the kingdom of the north
the kingdom of the mountain in the Vale
the Iron Islands the kingdom of the rock
the kingdom of the reach the Stormlands
and Dorne these regions had been
established by the first men thousands
of years before in the Age of Heroes one
hero of this fabled age was bran the
Builder bran raised the wall and built
the stronghold of Winterfell
establishing House Stark and reigning as
the first king in the north
other legends tell of the grey King in
the Iron Islands breaking to hammer mate
wife and defeated Nagas first sea dragon
house Greyjoy of Pike the current rulers
of the region claim to descend from him
how scarcely ruled the goldrich
westerland's from their mighty seat of
Casterly Rock but their lands and power
was swindled from them by the legendary
trickster land the clever the noble
house of Lannister said to have
descended from him the verdant and
fertile land of the reach were first
ruled by house gardener whose founder
known as Garth greenhand
wore a crown of flowers and vines he
roared from Highgarden as the first king
of the reach and was said to have made
the land bloom many noble houses trace
their bloodlines back to him including
the current Lords of Highgarden
House Tyrell in the Stormlands
according to ballads of the aged warrior
named Doran fell in love with Illinois
his father was god of the sea the mother
was goddess of the wind
she gave her Maidenhead to him
committing herself to a mortal life
enraged her parents called upon the
winds and waters destroying Darrin's
Bayside King and wiping out his wedding
guests Darrin declared war on the gods
and rebuilt his keep which was also
destroyed
for more castles he raised each stronger
than the last or fell to the power of
the God but Darren's seventh castle
storms end withstood the gods rage darn
became known as Dharan gods grief and
reigned as the first storm king there
are countless other tales from the Age
of Heroes too many to count
these histories weren't recorded in a
book but passed down from generation to
generation for story insult and while
some of them may be dismissed as fairy
tales every one of the Seven Kingdoms is
defined by them